en el último vídeo hablamos acerca de la
venta corta de una acción y me gustaría
hacer una recapitulación clara de lo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado para ello voy
a dibujar una línea del tiempo entonces
primero pongamos el título que era la
venta corta y ahora voy a dibujar mis
ejes entonces nuestro primero un eje de
las equis y un eje de leyes entonces
déjenme intentar hacerlo lo más claro
posible que quede muy bien está vamos a
decir que este es el eje de las equis y
para que arriba tenemos el eje de leyes
y bueno si ustedes recuerdan y vieron el
vídeo pasado hablábamos de la compañía
ibm y sus acciones cotizaban en 100
pesos en la bolsa de valores y teníamos
algo así y después caían es decir el
precio de las acciones caía súbitamente
y nosotros en un principio estábamos
parados por aquí este le voy a poner el
día 0 el día en donde empezamos nosotros
nuestra venta rápida de esta acción y
bueno para que nos quede mucho más claro
esto voy a hacer una hoja de balance
entonces voy a hacer una hoja de balance
de la venta
de esta acción la venta corta y bueno no
me voy a meter en problemas acerca de
los requisitos de la garantía entonces
voy a hablar solamente de activos y
pasivos y vamos a pensar que los activos
los pasivos o lo más sencillo posible
entonces de activo vamos a de suponer
que aquí tengo mi línea aquí tengo mis
pasivos y supongamos que yo tengo
ahorrado 60 pesos entonces lo voy a
poner aquí tengo hasta ahorita 60 pesos
y bueno a mí me da la corazonada para
hacer esta venta corta y yo creo que el
precio de la acción de ibm va a bajar
pero bueno desde cuenta que en el día
cero yo lo único que estoy viendo es
esto que tenemos aquí déjenme pintarlo
con otro color para que sea más claro
hasta el día cero yo lo único que he
visto es esto que tenemos aquí que la
acción de ibm sube y baja pero muy poco
y quién saben porque yo tengo un
presentimiento una corazonada un
sentimiento de que va a bajar el precio
de la acción de ibm por lo tanto qué es
lo que va a pasar pues bueno como lo
habíamos visto en el vídeo pasado lo que
va a hacer es pedir prestada la acción
por lo tanto tu activo aumenta a una
acción de ibm
y tu pasivo también aumenta en una
acción de ibm debes una acción de ibm y
entonces todo esto en el día 0 lo que
ocurría después era que tú ibas a vender
esta acción de ibm y tú la vendidas por
100 pesos porque eso es lo que valía en
el día cero por lo tanto estaba cotizada
en 100 pesos y tú decides venderla a 100
pesos la pediste prestada al corredor de
bolsa la vendes a 100 pesos y entonces
ya no tienes la acción de ibm tienes 100
pesos muy bien todo esto es en el día 0
y estábamos suponiendo que la acción iba
a bajar entonces baja y se estabilizaba
en un precio de 50 pesos entonces cae el
precio de la acción y ahí por el día va
suponer que pasaron 10 días entonces
aquí está el reporte de ibm por algunos
problemas de la empresa ibm no funciona
muy bien en un tiempo en un periodo de
tiempo y de hecho de prestaciones para
caer hasta 50 pesos lo voy a poner aquí
y entonces el reporte de ibm cambia las
acciones sobran no cotizan en 100 pesos
cotizan en 50 pesos y vamos a suponer
que pasaron 10 días del día 0 hasta el
día 10 y en ese momento te das cuenta
que la acción se está estabilizando en
50 pesos por lo tanto vamos a hacer otra
hoja de balance pero ahora para el día
10 que es lo que va a pasar bueno
primero tú tienes 60 pesos que a tu
ahorros de toda la vida más 100 pesos y
eso te da 160 pesos eso es lo que tienes
de activos y bueno de pasivos lo que
tienes es una acción de ibm es lo que tú
debes pasaron 10 días y ahora lo que
decides es comprar de nuevo la acción es
decir como tu corazón hace punto bajó el
precio y además crees que ya no va a
bajar más el precio de la acción de ibm
lo que va a hacer es comprar de nuevo la
acción pero no esperen no no no no lo
voy a comprar 100 pesos le voy a comprar
a menos se acuerdan le iba a comprar a
50 pesos porque ahora es el precio de la
acción entonces tú compras acción a 50
pesos de 50 pesos y obtienes a cambio
una acción de ibm y si modificamos la
hoja de balance ya no tiene 160 pesos
tiene 110 pesos y ya tiene su nación de
ibm que por cierto era lo que debías por
lo tanto vamos a pagarla y entonces ya
tampoco tienes una acción de ibm es el
abad entregar de nuevo el corredor de
bolsa y te quedaste con 110 pesos y
fíjate que padre está esto porque tú
empezaste con 60 pesos y después de 10
días
ahora tiene 110 pesos es decir tienes
una ganancia de 50 pesos y bueno eso es
lo que ocurre en un escenario muy
factible en donde como decíamos en el
vídeo pasado tuve el dista caro y compra
este aparato y así obtuviste una buena
ganancia ahora vamos a ver el segundo
caso ojo no todo es tan fácil el segundo
caso es el caso en donde metes la pata
es un caso terrorífico entonces
imagínate que aquí está de nuevo mi eje
que llega aquí está el precio de 100
pesos de la acción en el día cero de la
acción de ibm en el día cero y por
cierto vamos a suponer que este punto es
el día cero por lo tanto tenemos otra
vez la misma hoja de balance en donde tú
o tu vía 100 pesos después de vender la
acción que habías pedido prestada
entonces aquí estamos en el día cero
y qué crees unos pocos días después ibm
reporta que le ha ido muy bien mejor que
como había esperado y que las ventas han
aumentado bastante por lo tanto el
precio de la acción se eleva como cohete
y se estabiliza más o menos por aquí y
bueno en un principio tú dices espera
esto es una mala jugada pero baja del
precio en algún momento y después y como
entonces o no debe de bajar en algún
momento yo espero que baje y después de
otro tiempo dices honor no está bajando
nada aquí hay algo raro y me está
preocupando mucho el asunto y vamos a
suponer que cuando el precio en el
acción de ibm llega hasta 150 pesos tú
dices no puedo soportar esto ni un
momento más y es que aquí está una
dinámica negativa o de otra manera una
dinámica con un riesgo muy alto que está
ocurriendo en esta venta corta pues es
que puedes terminar perdiendo una
cantidad de dinero impresionante
entonces vamos a ver qué es lo que pasó
en el día a día donde tú decides comprar
de nuevo la acción en el día 10 la hoja
de balance decir lo siguiente tú tenías
160 pesos y debes una acción de ibm tu
pasivo es de una acción de ibm y tu
activo son 160 pesos
pero como tú ves que la acción sigue
creciente y creciente no sabes en qué
momento se va a estabilizar y dices ya
no puedo más necesito traerlo a través
de vueltas no voy a perder todo mi
dinero entonces tú decides comprar de
nuevo la acción y entonces de estos 160
pesos tú vas a gastar 150 pesos en
obtener de regreso la acción de hasta
150 pesos de estos 160 pesos por lo
tanto te quedan solamente 10 pesos y
obtienes de regreso a la acción de ibm y
con esta acción ya puedes regresar la de
nuevo al corredor de bolsas y así pagar
tu deuda pero fíjate que en este caso
solamente te quedaste con díaz pesos es
decir perdiste 50 pesos en este caso lo
que hiciste fue vender a un precio bajo
y comprar a un precio alto lo voy a
escribir aquí lo que hiciste fue vender
a un precio bajo y comprar a un precio
alto y bueno es que aquí está lo
importante de este vídeo porque en el
momento en el que tú decidiste traer de
vuelta la acción fue cuando la acción
valían 150 pesos pero puede ser que tú
digas no no la acción va a seguir
bajando así ir bajando y realmente siga
subiendo y puede ser que valga no sé en
un momento 200 pesos o 300 pesos
o una cantidad muy grande y tú pierdas
una cantidad de dinero infinita una
cantidad de dinero muy grande lo que va
a hacer que se rompa por completo tu
hoja de balance y pierdas el control y
quedes en la bancarrota y es que
realmente hay mucho riesgo en todo esto
porque si nos fijamos en el primer
escenario lo mejor que te podría pasar
es que la acción baje y baje y baje y
llegue hasta cero pesos es decir que a
ibm le vaya muy mal y por lo tanto tú
obtengas la ganancia mayor sin embargo
en el segundo escenario
puedes seguir creciendo y creciendo y
creciendo el precio de esta acción hasta
llegar a un valor inimaginable y por lo
tanto tu perder una cantidad de dinero
muy muy grande entonces hay que tener
mucho cuidado pues el riesgo que se
corre en estas ventas cortas es muy alto
y bueno en otro vídeo hablaremos con más
calma acerca de los requisitos de la
garantía y de otras cosas que por
ejemplo el corredor de bolsa lo que hace
es poderte asegurar lo más que se pueda
que esta venta corta de la acción va a
salir lo mejor posible aunque recuerda
que no siempre es factible es un riesgo
que se corre
nos vamos a ver mejor